foreign
[Music]
middle child two brothers were actually
very close but they live in different
states only child childhood obsessions
Christmas magic
my name is Michael you're a great dancer
you're a terrible liar and that's kid
I've always imagined that my life was
like a typical romantic comedy you were
so confident and you just sweeped off
your clothes like your strippered a
bachelorette party and I basically
shower with clothes on
don't just shut up now shall we go to
your place tonight here's my door before
we go in just open the door okay
what is this Michael oh you don't want
to oh my God they're in here too
much
you're very cool and I'm worried that
you're going to break my heart you know
that this is my friend Mike a friend yes
Mom just a friend what is going on here
who is this guy he's my boyfriend your
boyfriend I think it's a great kid we
may not look like it but we are actually
kind of hip oh my God we were gonna go
to Woodstock you know
I am let's just take a moment to
appreciate this beauty
get what is going on are you all right
calm down off the ledge Mike I'm seeing
a doctor tomorrow
I'm afraid the news isn't good
I was always afraid kit would break my
heart and eventually he did he broke it
opened
you have to run the race in front of you
because that's all there is look back
this is this is a rom-com and more of
the Love Story it can't you can't four
hours we promised all the beds are
occupied give my husband a bed well that
was Oscar worthy worked for Shirley
McLean
I'm sorry I never told you how good your
ass looks in your khaki pants that was
it great if you understood how beautiful
you are if you'd leave me thank you for
inviting us and it was Kit's idea I was
vehemently opposed to it
and like all love stories it never
actually ends
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]